if I haven't already made it clear in
these videos religions are very diverse
and to view any religion as a monolithic
fixed thing is highly misguided we have
talked a lot about Islam in these videos
which is primarily because my that is my
field of expertise and to add to the
myriad of ways that Islam has manifested
itself historically and today there is a
group known as the Quran lists but there
seems to be a general confusion about
who these Coronis or what quran ism is
referring to so let's sort of dive into
this question explore what the term
Quran ism actually is
[Music]
so Coronas ingenuity refers to mostly
contemporary movement in Islam that puts
a huge emphasis on the text of the Quran
and applying the law and practice of the
Islamic religion often at the expense of
the vast hadith literature in fact this
is one of the main components or
characteristic characteristics of Quran
ISM is that they tend to be very
skeptical of the hadith sometimes and
often even outright rejecting them
altogether now what is important to
remember is that in traditional Muslim
jurisprudence and well just Islam in
general the hadith are incredibly
important the Sunnah or example of the
Prophet Muhammad which the hadith
contained is is second only to the Quran
and importance in terms of text to the
traditional Sunni perspective for
example the Sunna of the Prophet is an
important part of revelation that
complements the Quran in that way and
that the Quran is not the only part of
revelation in fact because of the
vastness of the hadith literature and
the silence of the Quran on many parts
of law and practice one could arguably
say that the majority of the practice
and some beliefs of the Islamic religion
is based on the hadith the coronis in a
general sense want to reverse this
tradition and to use the Quran as its
only source and viewing the hadith as
often problematic and this is for a few
reasons to tell the historical account
in a short way the Prophet Muhammad
recites the Quran
during the last 22 years of his life
before passing away in 632 the Quran was
then compiled into a volume a few
decades later possibly under the rule of
both man had been a fan for the first
hundred years or so the early judges and
jurists used the Quran primarily as a
source of law but also complemented this
with personal reasoning caller:i as well
as soon on which is the plural of Sunna
and was a general ideal of the community
and respected people including of course
the Prophet Muhammad that one would sort
of take as inspiration hadith as in
stories about Muhammad as companions
were probably told and spread pretty
early on but were rarely written down or
compiled and was
rarely used in legal matters but as more
questions started to arise regarding
practices especially in very different
cultures and places in the new sort of
expanding Empire there were a group of
people often called the traditionalists
who over the course of the later eighth
and into the ninth century primarily
started to argue for a more strict
practice of Islamic law as well as
theology they were often very opposed to
rye in the individual reasoning of the
jurist or judge and they started to
favor and gather the hadith and applying
it in matters of law these questions
were for a long time a point of great
contention and debate and stretched
across boundaries of law and theology
one camp favoring reasoning and personal
intellect the other being more strict
and bound to the textual sources this
debate was so heated that even the
caliphs very famously got involved these
are generalizations of course and they
were probably more sort of a spectrum of
opinions rather than to clear science
like that the traditionalists are often
synonymous with the name al hadith or
the people of hadith because of their
emphasis on and collection of hadith
texts for differing reasons which is
hard to get into without easily falling
into subjective territory the
traditionalist would eventually gain the
upper hand in the second half of the
ninth century and was very much cemented
by the ideas of Imam Shafi the namesake
of the Shafi law school who formulated
the classical Sunni loosin elphic
science of jurisprudence according to
the standard law and practice is to be
derived from one the Quran to the
Prophet Sunnah exclusively which is
contained in the hadith three consensus
or edge ma and for analogy chaos in
other words there was no longer any room
for eye or personal reasoning while sort
of there are certain differences of
opinions on details and matters here and
there in terms of this in the different
law schools of Sunni and Shia Islam
generally all the schools of law would
follow the standards set by al Shafi and
the traditionalists or the added hadith
and thus the hadith came to the
prominence that it still has today so to
return to our main topic the Quran is
probably have their origin in the
Islamic we
four movements in the 19th century of
Nicole Islamic modernism which was sort
of headed by figures like Mohammad Abdu
in Egypt or Hamid Khan in India and
Muhammad Iqbal later on too and these
people were usually sort of skeptical or
more skeptical at least towards the
hadith but one couldn't really call them
quranists exactly the idea of this
Islamic modernism was to reimagine the
Islamic religion to adapt it to the so
called modern world through going back
to the early days of the religion when
according to their opinion rationalism
was encouraged and flourished and to
revive the idea of HD HOD or
reinterpretation which they felt had
been lost in the tradition in a way this
is a kind of anti tradition movement
which became very popular in the in the
late 19th and 20th centuries and has led
as I mentioned an early reader has led
to everything from Islamic feminism and
progressivism to things like salafism
and the Islamic states all based on this
idea of going back to the original
sources and the original state of the
religion which of course people have
interpreted very differently quran ism
also evolved out of this general
attitude towards tradition to them the
hadith aren't reliable sources of
legislation because they were written
down and collected often centuries after
the Prophet died and was also often used
as ideological tools in sort of debates
that were being held theologically and
legalistically in the early Muslim
community thus making them very colored
by things like bias according to one of
famous coronis Muhammad tel fixedly
quote what is obligatory for man does
not go beyond God's book if anything
other than the Quran had been necessary
for religion the Prophet would have
commanded its registration in writing
and God would have guaranteed its
preservation end quote they instead
believe that the Quran alone is
sufficient
coupled with human reasoning the hadith
Roth Encinas not only unreliable but
often problematic it is in fact in the
hadith that many of the aspects of Islam
that some people today consider
problematic in the contemporary world
come from for example in the Quran there
is no mention of any death penalty for
example and it's rather ambiguous when
it comes to things like homosexuality or
or women's rights but in the hadith we
do find things like death penalty and
stoning and and and things that would
appear to be rather sexist for example
and keep in mind this is not me bashing
the hadith there are so many things the
hadith that could be considered a very
beautiful I'm just stating that the
majority of law and practice in the
Islamic tradition has actually come at
least in its details has come from the
hadith the Quran is therefore argue that
the hadith and the various traditions
built upon it are often backwards or
frozen in time and to uphold a living
and vibrant breathing Islamic tradition
that is adapted to the modern world
one should reject them or at least
minimize their use but while this
movement in particular is a rather
modern one
it does have presidents in the early
Muslim community as well there were
critics and skeptics of hadith in the in
the early days of Islam as I mentioned
the widespread use of hadith was a later
development as most of the early judges
and jurors didn't make any extended use
of it really as they became more popular
there were many people who were critical
and skeptical of hadith including judges
famous theologians and even some abasa
DA lives this includes caliphs like Al
Mamun and famous theologians like wah
celebanator Alger Hiss there are even a
more and the most extreme case perhaps
Ibrahim and Nizam they much like the
modern Coronas not only view the hadith
as unreliable and amounted them to
guesswork they even view them as being
quote filled with contradictory
blasphemous and absurd traditions
scholars like the Ottoman armor were
posted the hadith because they were used
as polemical tools ideologically by the
traditionalists and al-hadith so as you
can see while the hadith eventually sort
of won the day and there were many who
were skeptical early on and this is the
argument of the Coronis as well they
argued that they are actually going back
to the early days of the community when
people valued things like personal
rational inquiry and and before the sort
of dogmatic ways of the annal hadith and
the hadith generally hadn't infected the
Muslim religion
yet the problem with this as I mentioned
is of course that the majority of
Islamic law and practice and ritual
comes from the hadith and this includes
very basic and and sensual practices
like daily prayers are fasting and all
these things so how does one tackle this
problem well there are multiple ways
some just practice the way it has been
practiced traditionally using the hadith
SAS inspiration praying five times a day
in the same way that most Muslims do and
simply just viewing the Quran as as the
main source and minimizing the role of
the hadith as such others have modified
the religious rituals as a result for
example many colonists only pray three
times a day as they argue that the Quran
only mentions three prayers is similar
to these smileys today in the prayer
itself they also don't do any
prostrations when sitting in prayer
instead they go straight from a standing
position to prostration and then right
back to standing the Quran are varied
today as well as I've said but they all
share the beliefs that the Quran is
perfect and the the hadith aren't needed
or are problematic for use in Islamic
law
there are many Coronas communities and
social media groups online today where
people discuss the Quran and the
religion from this particular
perspective as you might expect many
outspoken quranists of the last century
and today have been and are often
persecuted for their beliefs by some
more traditionally oriented Muslims the
Saudi scholar Hassan Farhan almaleki was
arrested and tried for extremism by the
Saudi regime for example others have had
to flee or even been assassinated
it is a standpoint or perspective that
seems to be growing today however and it
is a you could say a piece in the puzzle
that is Islam today that helps us
understand the vast diversity and
multifaceted of this basically
second-largest religion in the world and
as I've hopefully pointed out in this
video
it is a interpretation and a perspective
on Islam and it's tradition that is both
simultaneously very modern and very old
I'll see you next time
[Music]
you